in A Song of Ice and Fire and Game of
Thrones every Great Lord has a maester
an educated man who serves as a healer
tutor and advisor the maesters may seem
harmless but many fans and some
characters in the series think they're
up to something
something big so let's have a look the
Masters are an ancient order based in
the Citadel in Old Town which is kind of
like a university as a maester studies
he forges a chain made of many different
metals to be worn around his neck with
each link representing mastery of a
different kind of learning silver for
healing copper for history and so on
the Citadel is governed by a Conclave of
arch masters the highest-ranking masters
who each bare a mask ring and rod made
of the metal of their field of expertise
the Conclave also elects a Grandmaster
who advises the king in King's Landing
for the last forty years this has been
pay cell when masters complete their
training they give up their family name
and take vows of celibacy and service to
the realm that they're assigned to a
castle or keep in Westeros where they
serve whoever rules their healing
teaching advising and also managing the
Ravens that carry messages between
castles so what's so suspicious about
them the Lady of barrowton Barbary
Dustin deeply distrusts the maesters
calling them gray rats she points out
that the maesters actually have a lot of
power over the lords they supposedly
serve she says since masters often read
and write the letters for their Lords
they could possibly twist the words for
their own ends masters are supposed to
be politically neutral but because they
abandon their family names
you can't know who they truly are or
where they come from or whose interests
they might serve she says we make them
privy to all our shames and secrets a
part of every Council and before too
long the ruler has become the ruled
doesn't make some good points here right
masters are like the Google or Facebook
of Westeros they control the flow of
information and everyone just trusts or
hopes they're not being manipulated
maesters ride the history books
educate young lordlings count the votes
at councils and whisper into the ears of
the most powerful people in Westeros
could the maesters be manipulating
politics for their own purposes doston
goes on to claim that the maesters were
closely involved in a plot against the
Targaryen before Robert's rebellion so
at the start of the series before Tommen
and Joffrey Robert Baratheon is the king
of Westeros he became king about 20
years earlier when his rebellion
overthrew the Targaryen who had ruled
Westeros for the last 300 years
the rebellion began when Eddard Stark
sister lion-o was abducted by or maybe
ran away with Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
but lady Dustin implies that the Starks
along with the Tully's and maybe their
errands and Baratheon's had been
plotting a rebellion long before the war
began and that one of the main people
behind this plot was a maester named
Wallace apparently the son of an arch
made sure of the Citadel and a high
tower go house high tower is one of the
biggest supporters of the maesters so if
what lady Dustin is saying is true the
maesters of the Citadel may have been
partly responsible for Robert's
rebellion and the downfall of the
Targaryen x' a lot of this is uncertain
we don't really know the details but it
sure is intriguing and we hear a similar
but bigger claim from another character
Marwan the mage Marwan is an arch
maester of the Citadel but he's not like
other masters all stuffy and academic
Marwan reputedly keeps company with
[ __ ] and hedge wizards in rat pits and
black brothels and sacrifices to queer
gods he spent years in the distant East
searching for lost books studying with
warlocks and shadow binders and along
the way teaching Mary Mazda how to heal
marwan's mask is Valyrian steel meaning
here is an expert on magic at the end of
feast Sam Tolly meets Marwan and
marwan's that the maesters are
conspiring to build a world without
sorcery or prophecy or glass candles or
dragons the implies that the maesters
killed all the dragons the last time
around that they didn't trust maester
aemon because he was a Targaryen and
that the maesters are willing to kill to
further their goals Marwan then gets on
a boat and sails off to find Daenerys
leading Sam and the reader wondering
what the hell's to make of all that
so let's work it out Marwan is implying
that the maesters of the Citadel have
been
inspiring for many years against
Targaryen sand dragons and magic which
could make sense as the historians of
Westeros the maesters would be painfully
aware of the damage done to the realm by
the Targaryen sand their dragons through
war and misrule and madness
not to mention that several grandmasters
were killed by Targaryen Kings maybe the
maesters figured that the best way they
could serve the realm would be to get
rid of the Targaryen sand their
destructive dragons it's also no secret
that the maesters don't trust magic it's
easy to see why magics wild and
dangerous difficult to control and to
understand which is a real challenge to
the maesters power as scholars and
advisors so it probably would make sense
for the maces to oppose the Targaryen
dragons and magic can we find any
evidence that they've been conspiring
against these things we've already
talked about lady Dustin's claim that a
maester helped caused Robert's rebellion
which could possibly have been part of a
maester conspiracy against the Targaryen
s' we hear another claim from Marwan he
suggests that the maesters don't trust
maester aemon because he's a Targaryen
and that's why Amon spent his life on
the wall instead of becoming an arch
master at the Citadel however when Iman
talks about this stuff it sounds like it
was his choice to serve on the wall and
the official world of Ice and Fire up
says Amon went to the wall so he
wouldn't be used politically against his
brother egg the king so it doesn't
really sound like a maan was exiled from
the Citadel for being a Targaryen
further we know of at least one
Targaryen who did serve as an arch
maester of the Citadel although that was
admittedly a long time ago so none of
this is really evidence of a conspiracy
let's look at another of marwan's claims
he implies that the maesters killed all
the dragons the last time around the
last time around was about a hundred and
seventy years ago at a time during the
Targaryen reign of Westeros when they
had 21 dragons most of those dragons
were killed during the dance of the
Dragons a civil war of succession that
divided the Targaryen Xand their dragons
and pitted them against each other in
the three years of the war twelve
dragons were killed in battle five
dragons were killed by rioting mob of
common people two flew off and one
vanished leaving just one young dragon
caught more
a live and under Targaryen control there
are also some hatchlings after the war
but none survived long and apparently
mourning died too because within about
20 years the last Targaryen dragon was
dead there were still some eggs left
over after that but none of them ever
hatched well not until much later anyway
so it's not clear what Marwan means when
he claims that the maesters killed the
dragons the Dragons clearly died in this
huge Civil War maybe Marwan means that
the maesters killed off these last few
dragons somehow it has been suggested
that they might have been poisoned
because they were stunted and small in
fact the Dragons have been getting
smaller few years nah never grew as
large as the original three that Aegon
the conquerer brought from Valyria
the maester say that the reason the
dragons don't grow so large is because a
Targaryen started keeping them in an
enclosure in King's Landing called the
dragon pit though Daenerys dragons still
seem to grow fine when they're kept
chained up so maybe that's not true
either way it does seem possible that
the maesters might have poisoned the
last dragon hatchlings or stunted the
Dragons growth somehow but there's no
evidence for any of it and besides
that's hardly killing all the dragons is
it what killed the Dragons was the war
the dance of the Dragons so maybe what
Marwan means is that the maesters caused
that war like our lady Dustin claims
that the mesas helped caused Robert's
rebellion we learn about the origins of
the dance of the dragons in the princess
and the Queen and robed Prince novellas
as well as the world of Ice and Fire and
in these texts it doesn't look like the
maces were involved in the start of the
war in fact both grand maester Oh a land
grand maester run cedar try to prevent
the war from starting and maester Noren
helps a dragon and his right of flee the
war if you want to get a bit paranoid
you could point out that in universe
these texts are written by maesters who
may have covered up their own
involvement in the war it's possible
maybe but we are told that a septum and
a court jester also contributed to these
accounts making a maester cover-up seem
less likely so there's no clear evidence
that the maces were involved in causing
the war but we do know that the high
towers were queen alicent Hightower who
had married King viscera star garyun
wanted
son aegon to inherit the throne even
though the king himself wanted Rainier
of his daughter by his first wife to
inherit the throne that's basically the
conflict that led to the dance and the
deaths of the Dragons and it was in
large part caused by house Hightower the
same house that lady Dustin says was
connected to the maester who helped
caused Robert's rebellion and the same
house that's known to closely support
the maesters it doesn't seem likely that
the high towers were conspiring with the
maesters against the Targaryens because
the high towers have actually been very
loyal to the Targaryen but it might be
that the maesters manipulated the high
towers into starting the dance of the
Dragons in the same way that the
maesters apparently manipulated the
Starks durability as a Targaryen so we
still have no hard evidence but it does
seem very possible that the maces were
behind both the dance of the dragons and
Robert's rebellion the wars that killed
the dragons and overthrew the Targaryens
let's look at the other part of marwan's
claim he says the Masters of building a
world without sorcery or prophecy or
glass candles a world without magic this
is an interesting thing because
apparently at least until recently magic
has been in decline in Westeros Daenerys
says that magic had died in the West
when the doom fell on Valyria the doom
of Valyria was centuries ago and
happened very far away so the maesters
probably weren't involved though the
faceless men might have been but the
point is that now it seems that the
maces believe that Magic's no longer a
thing maester Luwin says that magic does
not work
perhaps magic was once a mighty force in
the world but no longer this view seems
to be shared by most other masters at
the Citadel part of a maesters training
involves spending a night in a darkened
room with a candle made of obsidian or
dragonglass lighting a glass candle
apparently requires magic and the whole
point of this procedure is to show
maesters that magic doesn't work so
what's the sense in the maesters having
a conspiracy against magic
if the maesters believe there is no
magic anymore maybe the maces have
realized the same thing that Queen and
Marwan have realized that glass candles
are burning magic is returning new
dragons have been born that others have
returned
Melisandre's magic grows stronger and
resurrections are happening left for
Center Leo Terrell says old powers waken
shadows stir an age of wonder and terror
will soon be upon us an age for gods and
heroes that does not sound like
something the mesas would want to happen
so maybe they're trying to stop it but
it's not clear how they would do that
it's not like they're covering up the
existence of magic they openly discuss
it in their books and they still have an
official position on their Conclave for
an arch Meister who's an expert on magic
so while it does make sense that the
maesters might oppose magic it's not
clear how they would do it so a big
maester conspiracy against Targaryen
sand dragons and magic is looking
possible but we still have zero solid
evidence that one exists let's try to
find some by having a look at some
individual maesters pycelle and kresson
pycelle is the grand maester he directly
advises the king of Westeros so he's one
of if not the most powerful masters if
there is a maester conspiracy pycelle
would surely be a part of it and pycelle
has done a lot to undermine the
Targaryen z' in book 1 when the small
council discusses what to do about
Daenerys pycelle advocates assassinating
her the most of the rest of the council
does too so that might not mean much but
there's a bigger thing during Robert's
rebellion pycelle convinced the Mad King
to open his gates to Tywin Lannister's
army which led to the sack of King's
Landing the death of King Aerys and the
end of the line of Targaryen Kings maybe
pycelle did these things as part of the
maesters conspiracy against the
Targaryen x' but a couple of times
pycelle gets really sharply interrogated
by Tyrion then by Cersei and in these
Saenz pycelle totally breaks down he's
weeping and whimpering on the floor and
he reveals his true motivation which
turns out not to be a conspiracy against
the Targaryen x' but a massive man crush
on Tywin Lannister pycelle says he's
Tywin's man that he hoped Tywin would
become king that all he did he did for
House Lannister in the world of Ice and
Fire pycelle says the gods made and
shaped Tywin to rule he goes on about
the man beneath the armor clearly it was
loyalty to Lannister not a conspiracy
against the Targaryen
that led Purcell to bring about the mad
Kings downfall of course you could claim
that this seemingly doddery old man is
actually a master of deception and is
hiding his true involvement in a
conspiracy
we couldn't rule him out unless we could
really see what he was thinking
fortunately we get to do exactly that in
the case of Cresson maester Cressen
serves Stannis Baratheon at Dragonstone
and in the prologue of clash Crescent
tries to kill the red witch Melisandre
which looks exactly like the sort of
thing that someone would do if they were
part of a conspiracy against magic the
chapter is written from Crescent's point
of view so we get to see all the maces
thoughts that lead to his decision to
try to kill Mel and opposition to magic
and superstition is part of crescens
motivation a sort of ideological battle
goes on between Melisandre magic and
crescents denial of it but that's not
the main issue here Crescent does have
his doubts about magic and there's no
mention of any conspiracy
crescens main motivation is that he
wants to protect Stannis Crescent loves
Stannis thinks of him as the son he
never had and he feels that Melisandre
is leading Stannis astray by convincing
him to kill his brother and to sail to
war without having allies so while magic
is part of the issue here the main
reason Crescent tries to kill Mel is not
a mystic conspiracy against magic but a
fatherly love for Stannis so where does
this leave us the maesters could have a
lot of influence on the politics of
Westeros they may have good reasons to
oppose to our gate Aryans dragons and
magic lady Dustin suggests that a
maester was involved in the plot to
overthrow the Targaryen s' though we
don't really know what happened there
now in the major claims of the maesters
killed off the dragons which they might
have done indirectly by manipulating the
high towers to start the dance or maybe
by poisoning the last few dragons but we
really don't have any proof grand
maester pycelle and maester Cressen make
moves against Targaryen sand magic users
but those acts don't seem related to any
conspiracy so given the complete lack of
evidence a big conspiracy involving many
maesters seems quite unlikely Mowen's
claims are probably exaggerated
in fact he might have an ulterior motive
for scaring off Sam from telling the
Citadel about Daenerys however it's very
easy to believe that at least some arch
mesas of the Citadel strongly distrust
Targaryen dragons and magic and might
occasionally pull some strings to oppose
these things so the bottom line is that
there's probably some sneaky [ __ ] going
on we just don't know how much the good
news is that we'll probably find out
more in the next book
right now many awesome characters are
converging on the Citadel Sam tally has
been sent to study and earn the maesters
chain Jack and higer has come in
disguise and acquired a key said to
unlock every door in the Citadel Oberyn
Martell's bastard daughter Sorella has
come in disguise as the acolyte Alerus
and some of you on Greyjoy's Ironborn
have started raiding around old town
there are a lot of disguises going on a
lot of intrigue lot of mystery it's
going to be a lot of fun seeing how all
this turns out and what it might reveal
about the maesters thanks for watching
feel free to comment about what you
think the maesters are up to thanks also
to touch all Tina's who kindly helped
out with some imagery for the video he
had some really awesome art based on
Game of Thrones theories so you should
definitely check out his deviantART as a
link in the description finally thank
you to all the patrons including Nicoli
derek wing ADC 400 and alice katrell who
made it possible for all chief Dax to go
full-time this year thanks to your
support we're already using better
faster software and hardware and aiming
to release at least 2 or 3 videos per
month hopefully more so with a new Game
of Thrones season coming out in April
2016 is going to be big so happy new
year and see you next time